là on était dans le haut le principal où
on arrivait donc on avait un petit stock
de pièces où on pouvait trier les pièces
voilà c'est une ville on entend les
oiseaux maintenant ça à l'abandon
donc nous la transition entre le moteur
exclusif est le moteur et blouson
l'avait déjà fait donc on travaillait on
faisait déjà des carter d'embrayage pour
les moteurs hybrides on arrête
d'ailleurs une ligne dédiée
spécifiquement pour renault
l'investissement était fait pour renault
donc c'est des machines qu'on
je dirais une deux ans
assez désolant c'est dégoûtant on est
écoeuré tout ça pour que d'autres s'en
mettre plein les poches c'est juste une
question d'argent
aujourd'hui on revient les constructeurs
stèle en tice 14 milliards de bénéfices
donc en plus pendant la crise duco vide
sacrifier dupe et abusé que ce soit
parce qu'elles anticipent à renault ou
l'état un pareil parce que l'état aussi
oui ou non vous en vous accompagnez on
va vous aider on va vous trouver des
solutions la seule solution qu'ils ont
pour nous c'est le reclassement ailleurs
ça donne trop envie de pleurer dieu
c'est des années des années regarde
là ça fait mal au coeur vous pouvez me
raconter votre histoire vous vous avez
travaillé longtemps ici comment comment
ça s'est passé qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous mais moi j'ai
travaillé 15 ans ici j'ai cru qu'il me
restait dix ans a travaillé pour moi
j'allais finir jusqu'à ma retraite et
puis ben may c'est un gros coup de
massue mais moi j accepte toujours pas
moi j accepte toujours pas la façon dont
ça a été fait moi je n'accepte toujours
qu'est ce que vous faisiez jgt
opératrice de fabrication et caristes
mes enfants ont travaillé ici mon petit
fils a fait son stage ici
là ça fait mal au coeur comment ça se
passe aujourd'hui pour vous
ben moi j'ai travaillé
tout le mois de février dans une
entreprise de plastique donc je voulais
voir autre chose que la métallurgie donc
ça me confirme que pour moi l'industrie
charrette
c'est fini pour mono industrie j'aime
projeter sur autre chose donc là je
passe mon permis de conduire parce que
je moi je vais m'occuper des personnages
du coeur opérateurs se pressent sur
henry et puis ça faisait plus de 2004
que je suis là et puis aujourd'hui
depuis le mad depuis septembre qu'on a
été liquidée bien sûr toujours suspect
on a du mal à trouver du boulot ici sur
saint claude c'est hyper compliqué quoi
c'est pas sûr saint-claude vraiment pour
avoir quelque chose il faut aller sur
yahoo sur les alentours qu'on va faire
30 40 km par jour quoi c'est un peu ça
au prix de du carillon aujourd'hui c'est
c'est un css de quoi
pourquoi ça marche pas ou pourquoi on a
l'impression que ça ne peut pas marcher
l'industrie en france
parce que nous avons des entrepreneurs
du cac 40 qui pensent plus à se ruer
dans les poches quand on voit les
rémunérations faut pas oublier que quand
même en france on est le pays qui est
rennais meurent les mieux les
actionnaires l'industrie ça marche pas
c'est parce qu'il ya pas d'entrepreneurs
industrielle en france dans la parc
il ya que des rentiers
vous ne disiez moi je suis venu de la
région nantaise pour boulot du coup
j'imagine euh non c'est plus parce que
la fonderie pour moi c'est
une passion contrairement à ce que
certains disent les français sont pas
des feignants ils ont qu'à venir bosser
un petit peu en entreprise et ils vont
voir ce que c'est politique c'est quoi
de bosser nom laisse pas derrière ne le
cul sur des riens de chaises
mais moi j'ai plus confiance en eux
pour moi c'est tous des menteurs de
toute façon j'ai décidé je voterai pas
vraiment des politiciens ils vous disent
que vous avez envie d'entendre pendant
les périodes électorales
après les élections et ben il oublie
tout tout ce qu'on regarde leur
programme c'est quoi ça parle de quoi
immigration musulmans voilà voilà ce
qu'on entend sur leurs pelles des
politiques voilà est-ce qu'il ya un vrai
problème derrière c'est juste ils
viennent juste à la chasse des voix et
plus d'une fois qu'on a voté on passe
aux oubliettes
[Musique]